course twinning and I don't know what  that is this is something I do to relax  I found my horse twin so you're like I'm  looking for a mall this sounds weird  actually a pale horse with long brown  hair horse it yeah for me that's my  worst twin and I was like I wonder if it  exists and it surely does it's also kind  of a weird al' yankovic right but so I  started doing this for my friends to  kind of cheer myself up so I did one for  Beth Behrs which is like a blonde horse  with bangs right right and I actually  did one for you you found you found my  horse screams take a long time to find  my horse twin you know there aren't a  lot of redheaded horses I know with your  with your stature you know a lot of tall  handsome red-haired horses very nice of  you to say but we found one  all right look at my horse Twitter  I love that horse matches my intensity  and raw sexuality yes very good all  right I'll be back  [Laughter]  you